yeah welcome to this video I'm playing
sky 1016 also let's see him benco know
benoni and i tend to get excellent
positions with this this line in fact i
even i think i actually even score fruit
22 yeah too few points compared to the
the positions that I'm that I'm getting
um ok so maybe here the bishop is not
too badly placed him in tending Bishop
age 6 always liked the idea to get rid
of the bishop yeah this is the FYE 5
coming here already yeah I think this is
already really bad for black ok I'm i
must say that i'm commander slightly
biased i mean usually if someone plays
the Benoni and doesn't know what he's
doing he's got this kind of position I
just basically busted already this is
this is just a deadly attack ok so how
to dismantle that that's that's cadets
open up the fr
the question is one question is should I
play d 6 or not this is not easy to say
nitey for we can maybe take and play at
five but the sex is probably right I
need Bishop c4 as an additional on
additional weapon so on let's do that
open open this up after the night
exchange and threatening Bishop g5 and
you cannot really play f5 because of
Bishop c4 or an IG five and then Bishop
c4 okay Bishop f5 yeah Bishop c4 is one
way to do it the efficiency for looks
looks dangerous I didn't really
calculate if he can take here but I
don't believe it be sure before I cannot
believe Bishop root kind of seven yeah
this is so much so how to continue here
you can have d6 now
it's probably not not too dangerous
okay maybe just 93 end and take it maybe
taking you can take with the real
consistent this isn't totally clear hmm
but retreating it feels it feels wrong
on my g5 him I know yeah why not Nyjah
fire if he takes takes Bishop f6 I can
take and play g4 and win the peace ok
it's opens very open this king but it's
it's a piece and I I maintain maintain
the attacking chances yeah yeah and it's
not so clear what so black should do now
I'm threatening G for you anyway
breaking through on f7 so I think it's
hard not to take now maybe maybe you can
find a move not with not taking
there are many attacking ideas f6 let's
look at five just one idea yeah yeah
still thought maybe g4 but
hard to say g 4g for Bishop e6 it's
still still not not although okay let's
uh let's just just take it Queen takes
does look everyone I don't know why is
yeah okay
this may be got f4 hmm I didn't think
about f4
okay look II seven takes I've got Queen
g5 this is the idea rookie seven Queen
g5 king of aid takes only 727 queen of
five and i have compensation for the
poem okay i probably overestimated to my
chances here ma'am maybe not I don't
know it's a it's it's difficult okay
intending Queen g6 check check so um
it's two pawns now not easy but I still
have an attack the bishop here combined
with them the default is worth something
okay
yeah this is really a problem now it's
got c4 now
and check hmm Joey I don't believe you
saw that before and we leave time or
game but can you do okay yeah this was
dis languaging resigns I mean this is
just unspeakably bad play because I mean
this is just a winning attack and I just
need to play it correctly which I didn't
okay yeah Bishop c4 a stronger and wins
okay yeah Bishop c4 first then be six
it's it cannot play it this way White
has got all pieces in the attack okay so
what I did is probably also good but not
not as clear Bishop g5 no wins okay yeah
this is good it is to totally clear
after such a game that the computer will
point out win after win after win it
doesn't help you need to find it
yourself the arbiter 35 per serve is
really really easy even yeah Bishop g5
if you cannot move the Queen we're here
d7 cannot go to rehab for what what what
should I play check this is this is
completely over with Queen age 6 made
yeah so if you have no move cannot play
f6 because of d7 it all falls apart and
if it takes takes the f7 collapsing yeah
ok I played this one what I actually
didn't see is that here g4 isn't really
helping much she can't play but should
be six so i played this and this is not
really working it's it's still an attack
but not not enough check check here can
play Bishop of seven I didn't see that
with Queen d6 check yeah this is
actually quite ok for what if i get if i
get this pawn this is compensation for
the porn not more I mean I I spoiled it
already a deformed check check and ok
the way we played he's able to play b5
and dumb yeah he's got the smooth he
must have it and as mentioned don't
think he saw this before I guys talk
doesn't matter um but the the
interesting point was that i put the
wrong pc on on g5 that's uh yeah Bishop
g5 this is the winner and as for the
opening the whole combination of Knight
e5 Bishop h8 is terrible I mean it just
invites a forehand and this attack and
black is just in a nightmare benoni
alright thanks for watching